so right now there's a big film out
there which we're all going to see which
is Oppenheimer right I thought it was
amazing I got serious physics Fanboy
Vibes I loved it so I thought it'd be
nice to sort of talk a little bit about
Oppenheimer but I didn't I didn't see
any point in talking about the the whole
atomic bomb project the Manhattan
Project because obviously that's big in
the film I thought I'd talk about some
of oppenheimer's great physics prior to
that of which there is some really great
physics so I picked out four papers that
I think are probably as much foremost
important papers in my view and the
funny thing about them is is that I
think every single one of these papers
now often having never won a Nobel Prize
right but I think every single one of
these four papers has led to somebody
else getting a Nobel Prize right this
just sort of demonstrates yeah
oftenheimer wasn't just about the
Manhattan Project and the leadership he
showed there whatever you think about
that is he he was he was a great
physicist and so I think we should talk
about that first paper right first paper
now they do mention this paper in the
film his paper with Max Bourne in 1927.
So Max ball was one of the um you know
great physicists with the Nobel Prize in
I think 1954 for his work on the
foundations of quantum mechanics but you
know who's granddaughter was
okay so what is this paper about this is
their 1927 paper on basically molecular
quantum mechanics as I said they talk
about it in the film but briefly so what
what is it what does it do what what
even is this okay so what they're doing
is so this is right at the beginning of
quantum mechanics and people are using
this new Theory to try to describe say
atoms and understand this sort of
spectrum of these atoms you know the
locations of their energy levels and so
on so these guys wanted to apply that to
molecules they're much more complicated
problem and but they wanted to
essentially try to figure things out for
for molecules how do but so I wanted to
I want to demonstrate kind of what they
did so I'm gonna I've got some I'm gonna
make a molecule right to try and
illustrate what what um
born in Oppenheimer did the molecules
have gone bloody everywhere okay so
these these aren't molecules these are
going to be my nuclei so I've got some
big molecule it's got well a big
molecule has lots of nuclei and lots of
electrons floating around so these are
the nuclei these are going to be the
nuclei imagine there's loads of these
guys right you know different Ukraine in
in this molecule and I've also got a
bunch of electrons
floating around them these are my
brothers old marbles I don't know why
I've got them but anyways
so we got rid of it
I have regret it already I got a load of
electrons floating around these these
nuclei very complex loads of there's
loads of electrons there's loads of
nuclei it's a very complex problem
mathematically so what what's what the
these guys were trying to do is they
were trying to apply Schrodinger's
equation to this to this problem
Schrodinger's equation is this sort of
it's the equation where one of the main
equations of quantum mechanics developed
a few years earlier by by Owen
Schrodinger and it allows you to sort of
calculate those those energy levels
those you know the spectral lines of
these whatever you're interested in an
atom or in this case a molecule for a
molecule it's complicated why because
you've got all these electrons with all
their different positions you've got all
these nuclei with all our different
positions there's some really
complicated equations to try to solve so
Oppenheimer and Bourne they said well
okay we need this is too hard we can't
we can't possibly handle this this way
so they they come with a really clever
approximation scheme to try to solve it
so you've got to remember that in
reality all these things are whizzing
around right they're moving about and so
on and so forth right but but what
bought an Oppenheimer realized was this
that actually these nuclei right these
guys are actually much heavier than
these electrons
okay so nuclei are much heavier so
there's an approximation which works
really well where you can assume that
these guys are not moving
okay whereas the electrons are so you
assume to some approximation that these
guys are not moving so you do the
calculation assuming that these guys are
fixed they're fixed in space and you
allow all the electrons to whiz around
and you you solve for the electronic
energy levels the energy levels from the
electronic system the electrons
themselves you solve that and you get an
answer and it's a number it's it's it's
an energy that depends on where you put
these
okay so if you put them in a slightly
different place you might get a slightly
different answer but whatever the answer
but they're still fixed but the answer
that you get for the energies of levels
of these this electronic system is
coming depends on the locations of these
things
okay so that's the first pass
then what they do is they feed that
answer for the electronic energy levels
into the full system again and they
start allowing these nuclei to move
okay
but they move in a potential set up by
the electrons that he's just calculated
and then they use that to then go again
with Schrodinger's equation and solve
for the full system and get the full set
of energy levels for the for the whole
molecule in a really really reducing the
complexity of the problem and getting a
really good approximation what are you
getting an approximation of the final
answer that spits out at the end
is energy levels it's the energy levels
it's the spectrum of the of the molecule
so the different energy levels that it
can have right so that's that's what
you're doing when you're doing quantum
physics this kind of thing you're
interested in so yeah that's that's what
they were after in much the same way
atoms have energy levels molecules have
energy levels exactly exactly but it's a
much more mathematically complicated
problem to solve in the case of
molecules because it just just look at
the mess there's so much stuff here and
I've only got three nuclei here in
reality you're going to have a lot more
okay so it's a very complicated problem
but they managed to find it's a classic
physicist technique let's look at a
problem let's Okay this is way too
complicated to solve I've got the right
equation but I can't solve that equation
as it is I need to figure out what is
the physics that allows me to sort of
get to an answer that I can use and the
physics here is that the nuclei are
actually just a lot a lot heavier than
the electrons
so interestingly this so this is really
really important result in chemistry so
I decided to ask Martin about it you
know I'm probably coffee does your
periodic videos
I asked him you know what's
give me a flavor of the impact of this
and I told me that he said yeah born up
and I'm an approximation it's really
really important in chemistry he said
but he hadn't realized until watching
the film that it was the same guy who
did the atomic Bob I was like lying come
on so the 20 the 2013 Nobel Prize for
chemistry was was basically really using
born Oppenheimer approximation and what
it did and there's even the born
Oppenheimer approximation is so
important in chemistry that is even a
branch of chemistry which is not doing
the born off and have approximation
that's how sort of embedded it is for
chemists so next paper Oppenheimer on
his own
really short paper not mentioned in the
film at all it's part of um it's only
two pages long as you can see I think
this is his anus mirabilis right you
know people talk about Einstein 1905 I
think 1930 was a really impressive year
for Oppenheimer some great papers that
year this is one of them this is where
he essentially predicts the existence of
positrons
just almost right it's it's over so just
a bit of History so a couple of years
earlier the rack had uh we talked about
Schrodinger's equation describing
quantum mechanics the thing about
Schrodinger's equation it's not it's not
relativistic equation it doesn't can't
doesn't deal with it doesn't include the
symmetries of Einstein's theory of
relativity it's a non-relativistic
equation so people wanted to extend
those ideas to to include Einstein's
theory of relativity so that's what
Dirac did Paul Dirac you know the
British physicist
and he he came up with it with an
equation which was a relativistic
version essentially of of quantum
mechanics and that equation was used to
describe the electron but one of the
weird things to to make it relativistic
it came at a catch there were extra
solutions to the equation so the
equations didn't just describe an
electron it predicted that there had to
be some other ingredient there another
type of particle that actually had the
opposite charge to the electron so
positive charge
so everyone's like well it's not like
it's another state of the electron
because it's not like the there's no
transition which takes the electron to a
positive the you know it's something
with positive charge that's not a thing
that exists so they really thought that
this extra solution to the Rex equation
had to be uh you know another particle
there should be a particle that with
positive charge that we can identify
with the other solution to the racks
equation and of course everybody at the
time was screaming well it's the proton
right obviously it's the proton right
well Oppenheimer wasn't so sure so he
looked at the arguments in favor of
people saying it had to be the proton
the rack himself was pushing for it to
be the proton Oppenheimer said no and
basically he's very really really simple
argument so he said if you think this
guy's the proton and this is the theory
describing both the proton and the
electron then when you scatter light
against against an electron it should
pretty much behave in the same way as
when you scatter light against a proton
and we know that it doesn't the the the
scattering is slightly different and the
difference is is rated by the difference
in their masses by the way
and so what Oppenheimer said is actually
this other solution to dirac's equation
it's not the proton it's got to be a it
must be another particle with positive
charge that has the same mass as the
electron
okay that is the property of the
positron but he stops short of
predicting that it should exist because
he didn't quite his interpretation was
he didn't quite buy the rack's theory
wasn't 100 taken by there were some
other calculations he'd done was he
thought were not quite agreeing with
experiments so he wasn't quite convinced
by it at that stage now dirac's equation
is basically right the Dirac himself
then took what Oppenheimer and Hermann
vile as well had said afterwards and
said right okay this is this is really
predicting another particle and he
predicted the positron essentially which
was then discovered a few years later
incidentally discovered it was
discovered by Anderson but
that he gets the credit for it Anderson
gets the credit for discovering the
positron but actually black it who
people who've seen the film will know
black it features in the film he's the
Cambridge professor at the start of the
film right he actually discovered it
first but he published after
so there's a little bit of another
connection to the film there but anyway
yeah positron's essentially predicted by
by Oppenheimer but he never got the
credit for it next one okay another 1930
paper very so
um is anas mirabilis in my view okay so
what's he doing here again he's playing
this is when he was working with
Wolfgang Paoli by the way Wolfgang Pali
great physicist another one of the
fathers of quantum mechanics probably
head of the power Exclusion Principle
which named after him very much a sort
of you know no-nonsense physicist as
well actually but he really respected
Oppenheimer in fact this is what he said
about Oppenheimer he said oppenheimer's
physics is always interesting but his
calculations are always wrong right so
but actually this is a calculation that
that uh that Paulie and sort of nudged
oftenham it towards that actually I
think he got the calculation right
anyway so what was it about well again
they were they were thinking about
Paulie in particular have been worried
about about the electron and in
particular something called the self
energy so what what's that so you think
about electronism people about the
electron as a point particle and they
were talking about it's a point particle
then a particle of charged particle
moves you know it responds to an
electromagnetic field right it moves
within him what partly realized was that
the electron itself
was creating its own electromagnetic
field
so it should have it should respond to
its own electromagnetic field and you
can think about this as it it sort of it
gives the the electron an energy
but the problem is the the energy that
you get from its electromagnetic its own
electromagnetic field if you do this
calculation classically because the
electromagnetic field blows up to
Infinity at the point of the electron
itself so does the energy it wants to
endow the electron with this self-energy
it blows up it becomes infinite so
partly realizes can't can't be right
okay the electron doesn't behave as if
it's got infinite energy which is the
same as infinite Mass it doesn't behave
like that so this had to be wrong
so he said well maybe this solution to
this which we're treating this problem
classically maybe we think about it
quantum mechanically using the racks
Theory we can take care of this we can
fix this problem
so we set Oppenheimer on it
so oftenheimer did the calculation I
decided to do the calculation not in a
in a sort of obscure setting but in this
he wanted to look at the calculation in
a physically meaningful setting so
something which where the quantities
you're actually calculating are
physically measurable
so we decided to look at the at the
energy levels of hydrogen of the
hydrogen atom
and the and you know and the electrons
in in orbits around it so so you
calculated this
and indeed he found that when he went to
sort of higher order in his
approximations that indeed an infinite
contribution
was always there so this energy of the
electron was always getting this
infinite contribution
you have to get it didn't happen at
first order approximation but when you
get to the next order higher order is
approximations this infinite
contribution appeared
now again his interpretation of this was
that theory is probably just wrong right
the the electron doesn't have this
Infinite Energy what it doesn't have
infinite Mass well this is obviously
just wrong but no
it wasn't wrong it was right it took
about 15 years later or so Feynman for
example schwinger tomanager they came up
with the theory of renormalization which
we should probably do a video out but
it's a whole other story but essentially
what what you do there is you realize
you can add an infinite correction to
this and come out with a finite answer
and you can do this in a consistent way
that all makes sense and you can make
concrete predictions okay so often
having missed that but he was his
calculation was really the seed for
trying to understand what was really
going on he sold a lot of seeds he did
sell a lot of seeds we do his final seed
yeah okay it's final seed
again this final one is is alluded to in
the film
it is work on black holes
and probably nowadays is you know well
it's hard to say which is the most
important but this is really important
so
there's actually a few papers this year
in 1939 he he started working on sort of
more asteroid type stuff you start
looking for example at the structure of
neutron stars and trying to find
equilibrium Solutions uh as solutions to
general relativity that could describe a
neutron star and one of the things he
realized there was was that that the
there was a maximum mass that a neutron
star could have
for it to be stable and in equilibrium
if you went beyond a certain mass in his
case he said it was 0.7 solar masses
actually
that character that's a bit of an
underestimate based on how he modeled
the star but the ideas were right his
physics was interesting
yeah exactly exactly so so it's probably
close it's a slightly higher number than
that but but the the fact is true there
is a maximum size that a neutron star
can have what and be stable okay and be
in equilibrium so he'd realize this
right he said okay well what if I go to
higher masses what happens then
well it we know it can't be a neutron
star we know it can't be stable
okay so what happens and he was the
first person to really start to think
about this and he realized he started
studying he realized that actually these
things were going to collapse into black
holes he was the first person to really
sort of model Anna in anything like a
realistic scenario and it's really cool
actually now with the sort of modern eye
you can really understand this paper in
a kind of a much deeper way and this is
essentially what he had so he set up a
problem often I was a great physician
that he had this this gnat for sort of
cutting through to cutting out all the
goth and zooming in on the real problem
and doing the right the interesting
approximation that captured all the
really essential physics so in this case
he just took a spherically symmetric
star okay that's approximation clearly
and he just assumed constant density
again approximation not realistic but
enough to capture the really important
physics
and he realized that outside the star
it would have a solution which was
schwarztel solution which is the
solution for a spherically symmetric
distribution of anything in in vacuum in
in in a in general relativity it's it's
the solution that if you take it to its
extreme you will get a black hole but he
had the star sitting there so it was
only the exterior solution which which
sort of
fed into schwar's child rights it wasn't
a black hole yet inside the star he
realized that the geometry the inside
the star was that of a basically a
universe a section of a of a
cosmological space-time that
had constant density
but actually it was a Contracting
universe
and so this model is the model of a star
was where you have this distribution of
a of um of mass
it's fairly symmetric distribution of
distribution of mass it won't be stable
it will shrink it will collapse
eventually that star will collapse to
within its Event Horizon
okay and then it now becomes a black
hole and he was the first person to
really realize that process could happen
and the other thing is he also talked
about what it would look like and it's
again the first time I think anybody
ever discussed this he realized that if
you were riding on the edge of the Stars
it was as it was um collapsing
then um you know let's say take
something like the sun and it was
collapsed into form of black hole take a
few hours right eventually it falls
behind the Event Horizon and then there
is no return after that but you know it
takes a few hours for that to happen say
in the case but for somebody watching
far away Oppenheimer realized it would
actually take an infinite amount of time
for that to happen this is this is
something this is one of these weird
quirks that when you look at a black
hole if you see somebody fall into a
black hole you actually if you're
watching from far away you never see
them fall in that guy falls in and he's
pretty pretty quickly ends up to
Spaghetti but you watching him you've
never actually seen them cross the Event
Horizon of the black hole so oftenham I
realized all this and this was this was
really a forerunner to to very early
days people weren't taking black holes
seriously but Oppenheimer really started
to do that
and Roger Penrose when he got his 2020
Nobel Prize really excited this paper as
the real inspiration for his work in the
1960s with Stephen Hawking on on black
holes being well black holes basically
so yeah his final paper oh by the way
this is really quite amazing actually
this paper this is the last of the ones
that that we uh that we've talked about
the date it was published I always
forgot to say this date it was published
September the 1st 1939. do you know what
else happened that day
was it the was it the start of the war
that was the day Hitler invaded Poland
this is an amazing coincidence race and
that was that's the and this is really
the last really significant paper that
that Oppenheimer right wrote published
on the day that the Hitler invaded
Parliament
check out the video description for some
links relating to this video to other
videos we've done with Tony and his book
fantastic numbers and where to find them
a journey to the edge of physics anyone
who's seen Tony's number file videos
will be unsurprised to learn there are
all sorts of huge numbers in this book
plus some fascinating and curious
physics
as I said links in the description